[Música]
qué placer saludarlos Mi nombre es
Ángela Gómez y estoy con ustedes para un
nuevo episodio del debate Turquía va a
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales este próximo 28 de mayo
tras una reñida pero también sorpresiva
a primera vuelta en la que revierte allí
verdogan obtuvo
49,51% de apoyos frente al
44,88% de que mala de cristal los
encuestadores se preguntan ahora qué
calcularon mal y también hay
incertidumbre sobre lo que pasará con el
país a continuación para comenzar
escuchemos al jefe de la junta electoral
turca
es claro que ninguno de los candidatos
ha obtenido la legibilidad prevista en
el artículo 4 de la ley número 6271
y nuestro comité ha decidido realizar la
segunda vuelta electoral el domingo 28
de mayo de 2023 según el calendario
electoral previamente anunciado
sobre el panorama México de este país
estratégico con salida al mar Negro que
contiene la migración Europea y que
negocia la salida de granos de Ucrania
en medio de la guerra vamos a conversar
con agustino y Vereda quien es académico
de la universidad iberoamericana y
maestro de en estudios de África y de
Asia también se conecta con el debate
Lucía siriani quien es licenciada de
tecnología y doctorante del programa de
estudios islámicos de la universidad
libre de Berlín además de miembro del
grupo de estudios sobre eurasia ambos
invitados desde Ciudad de México ya
estoy con ustedes Pero además nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de este
debate dejen sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de nuestras redes
sociales en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24- bajo es la etiqueta es en
numeral el debate f-24 y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como angelago f24
no olviden tampoco que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y también en TuneIn
y se abre este debate vamos a empezar
con la primera pregunta Muchas gracias a
Agustín y a Lucía por estar con nosotros
Agustín comienzo con usted el panorama
en Turquía no está nada claro con unos
números tan cerrados en la primera
vuelta lo que se quedaría en el aire Es
que la fortaleza de erdogan es una
aplastante frente a una coalición de
seis partidos que intenta desbancarlo
Qué herramientas utilizará erdogan para
convencer en esta semana
es una buena pregunta tenemos dos
semanas para ver qué qué puede hacer
cómo convencer al electorado pero así
como está la situación en este momento y
también considerando que
el partido akt y su Aliado Parece ser
que se llevaron la mayoría en el en el
congreso
todo parece ser que que erdogan quizá no
esté muy contento de no haber ganado la
primera vuelta pero se el panorama se ve
muy muy favorable para él en la segunda
vuelta
para que la oposición gane ese 5% que le
falta se ve cada vez más complicado
evidentemente no era la solución ideal
en la primera vuelta de las elecciones
pero digamos que tampoco le va mal de
Cara a una segunda vuelta y sobre esto
Le quiero preguntar a nuestra invitada
Lucía llega la oposición debilitada
después es de no haber logrado obtener
el resultado arrollador que estaba
esperando kirishroglu en la primera
vuelta Usted cree que al final no logró
convencer
no no creo que llega debilitada la
oposición pero sí creo que llegó a esta
situación en medio de muchos cambios y
muchas turbulencias al interior de la
alianza
Entonces
sí esperaban una victoria tal vez pero
con un margen muy pequeño en ese sentido
el resultado no fue sorprendente y la
cuestión es ver si pueden sostener la
estrategia por la que optaron al final
para la segunda vuelta porque lo que sí
se demostró fue que el voto nacionalista
es el más fuerte ahorita en Turquía y en
su última etapa debido a su
distanciamiento con el partido y que es
el partido más nacionalista con el cual
se había Aliado el segundo partido el
chp
es difícil
imaginar que puedan apelar al voto
nacionalista en ese sentido el hecho de
que el voto de nacionalista más duro
haya quedado tercer lugar es un factor
más que apoya al a la capel al partido
oficialista Bueno sobre este tema
Quisiera regresar a Agustín porque claro
es muy interesante hablar de lo que pasa
con con el voto nacionalista no porque
una de las mayores críticas hacia
erdogan Agustín ese precisamente este
autoritarismo que ha venido
caracterizando los últimos años de
gobierno de erdogan y que pues estas
puertas de entrar posiblemente a una
tercera década en el poder sin embargo
su postura sigue siendo fuerte Usted
cree que es el reflejo de la sociedad
turca
Definitivamente
hay un fenómeno curioso que en la
mayoría de los procesos políticos los
discursos más extremos son los que
suelen dominar un poco la conversación a
pesar de que no sean los que ganen los
más votos pero me gustaría llamar la
atención justamente a este proceso que
estamos viendo en Turquía que es algo
muy parecido a lo que estamos viendo en
Israel en cuyo en el caso de Israel
esos pequeños partidos que dominan la la
conversación pública eventualmente
empiezan a ganar algunos votos Y aunque
sea un porcentaje que uno diría Pues a
Cuánto es 5% cuánto es 10% en el
congreso es suficiente para no permitir
que las fuerzas tradicionales puedan
formar alianzas Y esto es algo que
estamos viendo por supuesto ahora en
Turquía que digamos vamos viendo como el
nacionalismo se está volviendo esta
fuerza que puede hacer o deshacer al
gobierno pero también lo en Israel y
también lo estamos viendo por ejemplo en
Alemania con el afd que también es muy
claro que ese ese pequeño porcentaje es
suficiente para forzar a un gobierno a
ir hacia un lado hacia el otro y sí uno
podría pensar que ciertamente este 10%
que que votó por el
por el partido más nacionalista
Pues sí será será esencial para la
victoria de quien queden en el segundo
en la segunda vuelta bueno estaba
hablando
Agustín acerca de los resultados que se
prevén en el parlamento sobre ello Lucía
la Alianza Popular de erdogan compuesta
por su partido acá con sus raíces
islamistas con sus socios nacionalistas
como estamos bien hablando también se
encamina a esta mayoría no son 321 de
los 600 de los 600 escaños los que se
espera que conserven que tanto le va a
beneficiar a erdogan esto en la segunda
vuelta
muchísimo de por sí ya el control
mediático que tienen ha sido un factor
muy importante Para orientar esta
elección y sobre todo para evitar el
impacto del terremoto no se esperaba que
el enojo por la situación con el
terremoto
pudiera ser el factor que más este
influyera en esta elección a favor de la
oposición en el último momento
y no ha sido así y en buena medida no ha
sido así por el control mediático casi
absoluto que tiene el gobierno entonces
pues mantener la mayoría en el
parlamento es asegurarse esa ese control
político del país y una continuidad
aunque estén en el momento en el que han
enfrentado El desafío más grande desde
su llegada al poder
sigue siendo este un factor crucial o
sea seis puntos porcentuales de venta
del partido oficialista prácticamente
les garantiza la victoria en la segunda
vuelta sin embargo usted nos decía hace
un momento que la oposición no llega
debilitada la segunda vuelta es decir
existe de todas maneras un gran poder
opositor que está en el país y eso se
nota en la polarización que hubo en las
elecciones sobre ello pues uno tiene que
preguntarse qué es lo que pasaría con
una eventual gobernabilidad de erdogano
para un nuevo término
aún pese a al debilitamiento
institucional que se ha dado durante sus
mandatos anteriores qué tanto podrían
ser una piedra en el zapato las alianzas
o la alianza opositora que se ha unido
para estos comicios
sí sin duda van a enfrentar Un gobierno
muy difícil no van a Como sucede en
cualquier caso en donde hay una elección
tan competida en donde el país está tan
dividido tan polarizado pero yo creo o
sea pienso que no llega a debilitada la
oposición en el sentido en el que ha
sido realmente notable la forma en la
que han logrado mantener las alianzas a
pesar de todas las fuerzas oficiales en
su contra
Entonces se podía haber esperado que les
fuera peor considerando las condiciones
adversas en las que tuvieron que
competir por eso Pienso que no llegan
debilitados sino que llegan demostrando
la suficiente flexibilidad para lograr
lo que lograron aunque aunque eso no sea
la victoria y que sí eso va a significar
un desafío para el próximo gobierno y
eventualmente si el próximo gobierno no
es capaz de manejar la crisis y si
aumenta el descontento puede llegar a
implicar un cambio de gobierno no se
logró ahorita en el corto en plazo de
esta elección pero no es imposible por
eso creo que no llega a debilitada la
oposición y que sí va a ser un obstáculo
un aspecto en el cual va a ser un
obstáculo interesante es por una medida
que se tomó antes de la elección que se
redujo el tope del 10% que se requería
para tener presencia en el parlamento y
al Siete por ciento Y eso implica que el
partido procurdo el antes que ahora
se llama izquierda verde
va a mantener su presencia en el
parlamento Y esa es el discurso opositor
más claramente distinto de la
mire
Agustín hay algo que llama la atención
es que si uno realiza la lectura hoy día
de los análisis alrededor de lo que
sucedió en la primera vuelta y lo que
podríamos esperar para una segunda
muchos coinciden en que erdogan llega
con favorabilidad para esta segunda
vuelta sin embargo después de que Lucía
nos explica sobre cómo en algunas
palabras sí podría hacer esto ya en sí
mismo una victoria para la oposición al
tener pues una parte importante del
electorado del país usted qué dice llega
llega la oposición con una victoria ya
en primera vuelta Pese a que el discurso
sea manejado de una manera diferente y
más con favorabilidad cierto
Sí
en otros espacios
aquí mismo en 24 hace unos seis meses lo
que comentábamos era que se veía muy
complicado que la que hubiera un
candidato de oposición que realmente
pudiera hacerle frente a erdogan
entonces veas algunos meses para ahora
el hecho de que la oposición pudiera
formarse en una alianza y que las
fuerzas oficiales no pudieran evitar que
estuvieran las boletas
fue para mí fue una sorpresa
el hecho de que dijeran que además
podría haber ganado la elecciones de
allá
Pues sí sustancialmente distinto de lo
que hubiéramos estado hablando hace ya
no seis meses hace cuatro meses entonces
sí sí es un es un paso muy importante
para la oposición pero
aún más allá y sí concuerdo con con
Lucía que en efecto es un es un buen
resultado para la oposición a pesar de
las condiciones que tienen Aunque
sabemos que erdogan es muy muy y ha
demostrado ser muy habilidoso para
deshacerse de sus enemigos y uno de sus
enemigos creo que importantes que que
vas Va a ser relevante en el futuro
también es esta idea de los medios como
una fuerza oficialista por qué Porque
Durante los últimos quizá mes y medio
estuvieron diciendo que erdogan iba a
perder Y entonces
de por sí ya la prensa libre tiene una
situación complicada en Turquía después
de haber sacado este tipo de encuestas
diciendo que erdogan podía perder y yo
creo que
va a ser un poco más complicado su
relación con con el gobierno pero por lo
pronto si parece como un un buen paso
hacia adelante de la de la oposición y
sobre todo habrá que poner el ojo en sus
ganancias digamos en
en regiones específicas donde también a
futuro permitirá como lo vimos en
Estambul que vayan teniendo una fuerza
mucho más sólida y un voto Mucho más
duro a largo plazo que dentro de cinco
años yo creo que sí podría representar
que gane la presidencia bueno y ahí
podríamos poner en foco si le parece las
zonas afectadas por el más reciente
terremoto no porque después de las
declaraciones que diodo gane al final es
de las votaciones él lo que aseguró fue
que sus electores votaron con mucho
entusiasmo usando esas palabras en las
zonas más afectadas qué opina de esa
declaración o qué opinan los dos de esa
declaración porque lo que se estaba
esperando y a lo que hacían alusión
mucho los medios de comunicación era a
un voto de castigo por un mal manejo de
los terremotos entonces ahí opinan
ustedes por un lado está una oportunidad
para capitalizar por parte de la
oposición Pero por otro lado
las promesas de erdogan no de cara por
ejemplo bajar la inflación comienzo con
Lucía
yo creo que justamente se mantuvo la
fecha de esta elección a pesar de que
después del terremoto lo primero que se
preguntó fue si se iba a sostener la
fecha de la elección
Tan pronto después del terremoto
considerando las circunstancias incluso
físicas para para tener la elección y se
mantuvo en buena medida porque el
cálculo que fue acertado Es que para que
se llegara a una situación de voto de
castigo para que se llegara a una
situación en donde se impactó se pudiera
ver en las boletas tenía que pasar más
tiempo
en un tiempo corto ellos podían
controlar la información que salió y eso
es la estrategia principal que
utilizaron o sea los medios
prácticamente no podían transmitir
ninguna información negativa todas eran
historias sobre rescates milagrosos
etcétera y no se estaba permitiendo el
flujo de información crítica sobre el
manejo de la emergencia sobre las
condiciones que dieron lugar a este
desastre etcétera entonces no hubo
tiempo para que se consolidara esa
sensación en contra y que realmente
definiera la elección podía haber sido
de haber pasado un poco después
un poco más de tiempo y justamente como
como dice Agustín que las voces de los
medios críticos encontraran como los
recovecos para este para lograr cambiar
esa esa impresión entonces bueno en esta
región entusiasmo es una palabra este
evidentemente muy controversial no O sea
en medio del en medio del desastre
todavía un desastre que va a tomar años
sino décadas más o menos ir este
calmando pues entusiasmo No puede haber
incluso es una zona que está sobre la
cual se declaró un estado de excepción y
la zona más afectada también es la zona
que de por sí no tenía
el mayor apoyo el gobierno no estamos
hablando también de la región de mayoría
kurda en el sureste del país que se vio
muy afectada y en esta región Pues el
este la alianza de izquierda de el
partido verde de izquierda es la que
obtiene la mayoría de los votos es la
que como decía antes está más alejada
entonces ahí también hubo presencia
militar durante la durante las
elecciones Entonces digamos que sí
entusiasmo evidentemente yo no estaría
de acuerdo con que hubo entusiasmo pero
sin duda entre sus electores sí entre el
voto duro que tiene sí hubo una
actitud de mucha determinación de
sostener este gobierno Agustín Usted qué
opina porque justamente hace dos décadas
erdogan el propio erdogan hizo
capitalización de un terremoto para
llegar al poder y Esto fue digamos el
impulso final para las masas que movió y
que hoy en día sigue moviendo qué opina
sobre sobre el papel de estas zonas
afectadas
sí totalmente creo que estaba claramente
está muy consciente de de la importancia
de este tipo de
desastres que que por supuesto le
permitieron entrar a la puerta grande en
el 99 y creo que no le no pierde la el
significado de este tipo de eventos
pero al mismo tiempo como decía Lucía yo
en su momento pensé que iban a empujar
las elecciones a otra fecha pero sí ya
en retrospectiva ciertamente tiene
sentido más bien aprovechar el caos que
Todavía existe en la región a mí de las
cosas que más me sorprenden hay dos
cosas que me
sorprendieron una es que
el consejo electoral reportar 88% de
participación que sinceramente me parece
muy alto
el consejo electoral en general tiene
tiene fama de ser independiente pero sí
me parece sospechosamente alto el nivel
de participación a menos de que tú
quieras de que Lucía tenga como un poco
más el pulso de qué tan motivado estaba
la población en general pero una de las
cosas que estamos observando antes de la
elección es que tanto la gente en zona
afectada
poder podía ir a votar habla estamos
hablando de varios millones de personas
que están como desplazados internos es
decir que no están viviendo en un lugar
donde no están registrados para votar
e incluso Si siguen viviendo en el mismo
lugar no tienen mucha motivación en
efecto no están emocionados por ir a
votar No pues claro es que no va a ser
la prioridad pero es que además los las
propias empresas encuestadoras después
de pues este resultado tan contrario a
lo que habían predicho también dijeron
que había sido muy difícil de recabar
las opiniones de las personas en las
zonas de desastre Y pues con la
emergencia en general la contingencia
que se dio a partir del terremoto pero
pero es que hay que entender de todas
maneras Agustín a la sociedad turca no y
a su profunda relación con el islamismo
de la cual pues ha hecho un gran uso
erdogan una postura religioso religiosa
en el islam de que lo ha puesto cada vez
en una posición de mayor autoritarismo
pero ahí también reside diría usted una
gran base de su apoyo popular
Sí justamente estas zonas que también
son las que fueron afectados por el por
el terremoto son de las bases de voto de
erdogan que es en efecto técnicamente
todavía es este secular pero hemos visto
desde que inició en en su gobierno hasta
ahora en los últimos 20 años cómo ha ido
gravitando cada vez más hacia
hacia el islamismo hacia el islam
político pero aquí uno de los de las
cosas que en este momento estoy pensando
Más allá de
un vuelco
islamista mi principal preocupación
después de que digamos se asiente el
polvo de las de la segunda vuelta
es si Turquía va a retomar esta idea de
la ofensiva en en Siria contra los
kurdos y creo que ahí sí le pasaría la
también la pregunta a Lucía
si cree probable y yo la verdad es que
lo que es lo que esperaría para como
apaciguar este voto de nacionalista Y
consolidar
pues sí las credenciales de este
gobierno que va va a ganar pero va a
ganar por muy poquito que se sientan
forzados a renovar las hostilidades en
contra los kurdos
tanto en Turquía como Siria
Lucía tiene la palabra Muchas gracias
este Sí yo creo que
volviendo al tema del islamismo yo
quisiera hacer ahí una acotación
chiquita no
sin duda esa el discurso en torno a la
identidad islámica fue la carta fuerte
de duan durante sus primeros diez años
de gobierno y más bien lo que ha
cambiado en los últimos años es que se
dieron cuenta de que eso ya no era
suficiente por eso vemos crecer tanto la
asociación con el nacionalismo incluso
recurrir a muy viejos tropos
nacionalistas que estaban más bien
asociados con el partido republicano el
que ahora es líder de la oposición
Entonces en ese sentido hoy en día
Aunque siempre la el discurso sobre la
identidad religiosa va a ser importante
para el akp ya no me parece que es el
aspecto determinante ahorita el aspecto
determinante es pelearse por Quién
controla el discurso nacionalista Quién
es el que está guiando el discurso
nacionalista que ya se probó en las
urnas en ambos lados que es el más
fuerte ahorita electoralmente y en eso
de nuevo estoy de acuerdo con algo en
Agustín es un riesgo muy grande para
la relación con las minorías no turcas
dentro y alrededor de Turquía
particularmente los curdos que son La
minoría no turca más grande dentro del
país y en la frontera entonces
hay muchos contextos que ven que hacen
que
en particular Hernán vuelva más duro su
discurso en contra o promesas
militaristas de ataques a los kurdos en
Siria hay muchos contextos en donde él
Utiliza este este discurso pero yo creo
que es mucho más probable que lo
utilicen contextos preelectorales que en
contextos Post electorales porque una
vez que ya organizó su gobierno en
realidad ya no tiene tanta necesidad de
acudir a esto a menos que una situación
geopolítica
lo orille a eso algo que tenga más que
ver con si se orienta más a hacia
moverse a una alianza euroasiática o a
mantener los compromisos actuales de
Turquía con
los poderes occidentales en ese sentido
Lucía Cuáles son las promesas que deben
interiorizar o hacer los candidatos
interiorizar a la ciudadanía alrededor
de la crisis por ejemplo política del
país de la crisis económica del país y
de temas como los de las minorías que
tanto podrían prometer en estas semanas
que les quedan para convencer antes de
la segunda vuelta
yo creo que ahorita justamente el pleito
es por principalmente ver quién se queda
con el cinco por ciento de los votos de
lo que fue el tercer partido no el
partido nacionalista que quedó en tercer
lugar ese cinco por ciento de los votos
va a ser crucial este y por evitar que
la oposición pueda hacer un cambio
significativo no este ahorita es la
estrategia que sea que ha demostrado ser
más efectivo entonces
No necesariamente el hecho de que sinan
este candidato nacionalista apoyara a
una alianza o a otra significa que su
electorado inmediatamente se va a ir con
unos o con otros No necesariamente sobre
todo para Quienes son desde el mismo
nacionalismo críticos con erdon este
Pero yo creo que sí en estas en este
tiempo tan breve pues
el principal intento va a ser como
ganarse este esos votos que son ahorita
los definitivos yo creo que ya la parte
de la oposición que quería ejercer un
voto de castigo contra errón esa ya
salió a votar esa ya no va a poder
fortalecerse mucho más
Agustín usted como pronostica que va a
ser la movilidad desde ese 5% de los
votos que se llevó sin anogan sería
al parecer la clave para la segunda
vuelta del 28 de mayo
Sí definitivamente es la clave 5% es
bastante
pero sí pensando que le falta punto
cinco por ciento para llegar al 50%
en realidad es un es una brecha muy
pequeña que hay que cubrir pero digamos
todavía podría haber una una sorpresa a
mí lo que me parece es que
erdoan podrá intentar enfocarse en la
idea de reconstrucción y no no tanto por
tratar de atraer a los votantes en las
zonas afectadas sino porque en general
la idea de reconstrucción pagada por el
estado es una manera de estimular la
economía que te permita hablar también
de estas promesas de mejorar la economía
en el futuro que
aunque las prometo ninguno de los dos
candidatos creo que puedan cumplir con
la promesa de mejorar la economía turca
en el corto ni en el mediano plazo
especialmente por la debilidad de la
lira Pero sí yo creo que
erdogan se va a enfocar en
reconstrucción como esta idea de de que
es una inyección de dinero a la economía
que es de muy corto plazo y que puede
puede haber efectos económicos rápidos
mientras que si me parece que de del
lado del chp
el mensaje va a ser yo esperaría por lo
menos
en temas económicos de mejor de mantener
a raya la inflación y de hacerle honor a
la imagen de ataturque que al final del
día siguen teniendo
Pues sí ese
Pues esa herencia histórica con la que
el partido con asociado con con esta
figura histórica que que además en este
año
se cumple un aniversario importante
entonces
asumo que que se enfoque economía y
secularismo tipo ataque que también
tiene un poco de nacionalismo pero yo
pensaría que ese va a ser el principal
mensaje secularismo que sin embargo no
ha sido digamos el mayor fuerte con
erdogan al frente Usted cree que esta
polarización que claramente se ve
reflejada en las cifras de las
elecciones
es un tema en el que deberíamos trabajar
es decir aquí una gran pregunta es Cómo
superar Esta división este escenario de
total polarización en la que los
candidatos quedan tan cerca uno del otro
que no se ve una postura Clara dentro
del país y que a quien gane pues le va a
afectar le va a afectar en su
gobernabilidad y le va a afectar Pues en
el trabajo que tiene que hacer desde
aquí en adelante
[Música]
y es una es una tendencia que también
vemos en otros países
particularmente con la separación de del
tipo de votantes
en Turquía es muy clara la separación O
se va a intensificando la separación
entre el votante de una zona urbana
grande y el votante rural un poquito lo
que vimos con Trump que que sí O sea
Estados Unidos se dividió y sigue
dividido y
tienen demográficos muy bien definidos
en Turquía y me parece que rogan lo ha
sabido explotar muy bien
ha sabido dividir muy bien su
demográfico y la separación entre el
Turquía urbano y el Turquía rural o
bueno No necesariamente rural pero de
ciudades pequeñas sí Yo solo veo que
Sigue avanzando y que es una es una
tarea importante que debería de atacar
el gobierno pero que en términos de
electorales no les conviene y no creo
que lo quieran hacer pero en términos
digamos de para el bienestar de la
nación creo que sería de la
reconciliación entre los distintos tipos
de Turquía los distintos mundos que
conviven en ese país que es muy grande
creo que sí Debería ser de las cosas
principales Pero veo poco apetito de de
Buscar este discurso de unidad bueno
hablando sobre ese bienestar del país
Lucía qué repercusiones va a tener la
reelección de erdoganes y esta llega a
darse para la institucionalidad del país
Bueno yo creo que lo más peligroso en
este sentido Es que
la situación de la persecución política
y de la del autoritarismo van a
continuar y probablemente empeorar no
veo muy difícil aunque tenga mucha
presencia en el parlamento la oposición
que puedan hacer mucho para impedirlo
porque este ha sido el camino que ha
sido exitoso Durante los últimos 10 años
desgraciadamente O sea que ha sido
exitoso políticamente para errón y para
su partido
entonces una cosa que me parece
preocupante es esa otra tendencia que me
parece muy preocupante es que dentro de
ese discurso nacionalista ha ido
creciendo una narrativa contra la
inmigración particularmente contra la
inmigración árabe ha ido creciendo un
discurso muy racista en contra de
particularmente los refugiados sirios
entonces esa situación tampoco veo que
vaya a mejorar
a causa de esto y otra consecuencia la
probable es que bueno las personas que
sean autoexiliado en otros países la la
oposición política o incluso las
personas como disidentes en otros
aspectos que han buscado refugio en el
extranjero pues no tienen esperanza de
poder volver pronto a su país esa es
otra consecuencia en términos de
bienestar que me parece muy triste luego
la pregunta respecto a la economía
lo que decía Agustín de que nadie tiene
la capacidad ahorita de resolver la
crisis en la que ya está hundida Turquía
Me parece muy cierto y creo que es peor
que eso o sea creo que no solamente
nadie tiene la capacidad para resolver
esa crisis en el corto mediano plazo
sino que es más o menos impredecible
hasta dónde puede llegar la actual
estrategia económica del gobierno porque
tenemos una economía inflada fuera de
proporciones conocidas o sea niveles de
inflación que han sido combatidos con
medidas muy hetero y que no han
funcionado más que para apaciguar al
electorado no O sea lo que ha hecho ha
sido compensar eso pues con aumentando
los salarios lo cual Pues también
mantiene inflada la economía ofreciendo
jubilaciones a personas Pues todavía muy
jóvenes etcétera Entonces digamos estas
medidas de de populismo para para
mantener a raya el descontento por las
políticas económicas estas medidas
cortoplacistas han ido funcionando en
términos políticos y electorales Pero la
pregunta es hasta dónde la economía
turca puede ir puede aguantar esta
situación no Y eso Pues es lo que más
afecta directamente en términos del
bienestar de toda la población
ya tenemos que ir cerrando se nos acaba
rápidamente el tiempo había dos
preguntas que quería hacerles a cada uno
en lamentablemente no va a alcanzar el
tiempo para que los dos la respondan y
es Agustín dirigiéndome usted hasta qué
punto va a ser importante el trabajo que
Turquía estaría proyectando respecto de
Siria que acaba de ser bienvenida de
nuevo a la liga árabe Hace algunos días
veíamos en Moscú una reunión de
relanzamiento de las relaciones entre
áncara y Damasco con la presencia de
Irán Pues por supuesto con la presencia
de Moscú que auspició la reunión pues
esto fue una movida claramente antes de
las elecciones
[Música]
sí entre otras cosas
erdogan siempre ha mantenido sus
relaciones exteriores como una
herramienta de política interior
eso claramente seguirá y alimenta mucho
al ego nacionalista
demostrar que Turquía sigue siendo una
sino una potencia mundial una potencia
región regional que permite digamos que
tiene por el cuello a la otan y que al
mismo tiempo
Estados Unidos se lleva bien con Estados
Unidos o comillas se lleva bien pero
bueno tiene relación con Estados Unidos
y con con Rusia tiene una mano
importante en el conflicto en el cáucaso
entre azerbaiyán y Armenia una mano
importante en el conflicto en Siria
Entonces esta capacidad de proyección
Incluso si no tiene réditos muy
patentes digamos no no no no son buen
negocio en términos dinero constante y
sonante para Turquía si alimentan mucho
el ego nacionalista Y sí esperaría que
Turquía a través de las redes que ya he
hecho el particularmente en estos
conflictos que ya me menciona ya
mencionamos que mencionabas muy bien
también sobre Ucrania el cáucaso Siria y
uno que suele pasar debajo del radar el
norte de chipre yo creo que la la
posición de de erdogan pues se
endurecerá de por sí ya está bastante
inamovible lo cual seguirá proyectándose
lo que no es ninguna sorpresa nos queda
menos de un minuto y quisiera
preguntarle a nuestra invitada para
cerrar Ucrania Cómo se verán afectadas
las relaciones con Ucrania donde Turquía
también tiene metida la mano ampliamente
con por ejemplo el acuerdo de granos
en ese sentido yo quiero de hecho
reiterar lo que ya dijo ya dijo Agustín
Porque no tenemos mucho tiempo para
elaborar mucho yo creo que se van a van
a apostar por mantener la misma
estrategia de usufructuar una posición
de negociación de estar con un pie en un
lado y otro pie en el otro lado de ese
gran conflicto geopolítico para sacar de
ello el mayor provecho al interior y al
exterior y yo espero que también para
fortalecerse militarmente que es una una
de las agendas importantes de turquías
eh fortalecerse en el sector militar Y
en el sector energético pues miren yo
les agradezco mucho a los dos por
ampliarnos lo que es el panorama de
Turquía de todas maneras está la
expectativa de todas maneras está la
incertidumbre de lo que podría pasar en
esta segunda vuelta electoral eran eh
Lucía siriani licenciada de tecnología y
doctorante de estudios islámicos de la
Universidad de libre de Berlín y también
Agustín Vereda académico de la
universidad iberoamericana y maestro en
estudios de África y África
a ustedes dos Muchas gracias y bueno eso
es todo por hoy En nombre del equipo
técnico Les agradecemos por su sintonía
la producción de este programa estuvo a
cargo de Andrés doncell la producción de
los invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en nuestras
redes sociales nos vemos mañana
[Música]